okay everyone I'm so excited today
because I am joined by Georgia wigam and
Max Burkholder who star in Ted the full
seasons on peacock today how you guys
doing today good good how are you how
are you good I'm so excited to talk to
you guys I absolutely love this show
it's hysterical and I'm wondering
because it's in a '90s setting Georgia
did you learn anything for the first
time on the show you didn't know about
the 90s just being in that setting yeah
a lot um I I I was I consider myself a
little bit ignorant coming into it cuz I
had to do a lot of research on certain
things uh Plinko is a big one didn't
know what Plinko was so uh that's a
brand new one for me um but I think just
like you know
also reminding myself of some of the
technology that was around then because
we did grow up with some of it but you
know it faded out kind of quick I had a
Nintendo 64 growing up yeah yeah exactly
so and a VCR you know we had those but
it's like a just reminding you know it's
reminiscent it's weird yeah and if it's
cool for the viewers feeling that way
too and getting that like 90s Nostalgia
again and it's cool you guys connected
to it and uh Max you posted on Instagram
that when you you were sent the Ted doll
before shooting you brought it with you
on the town so I'm wondering how far did
you take this like did you have the doll
in your room with you breakfast oh yeah
well I mean they they sent everybody in
the cast a life-sized Ted doll When We
Were cast and the instructions we were
given was you know like live with it
talk to him like bring him around with
you just get used to where his body is
in space cuz when we're doing the show
there's nothing there it's you're
talking to empty space so I did two
things one was I brought him around to a
bunch of bars and had a lot of fun uh
with people being like why why is Ted
from the movie there and I would just be
like oh that's my best friend just sort
of keep people in the dark and um the
way I did it was I would tape my phone
to his his head and FaceTime people so
that I just got an experience of like
what it's like talking to him in space
wow yeah I took him I took him uh I took
him on the 101 and I stopped with him in
traffic that's like like keep I buckled
them in and we were we were in traffic
and people would kind of be like what
they you know and just you have to just
be like yeah that's don't worry about it
you know don't don't don't ask questions
you should
they were seeing something that wasn't
there yeah wa what are you talking yeah
no everything you do for the arc that's
great uh Georgia at any point was Blair
going to have a Boston accent like how
did you kind of come about and get out
of that one because I feel that's such a
challenge in general I don't know I just
I think you know that's it was it was I
got very lucky um no I would I was
looking forward to doing it when I got
cast but I also knew that it was a huge
Challenge and I you know I I you know
Max showed me up already like he came he
came with this amazing accent he sounds
like Mark Wahlberg and I was like thank
God I didn't have to do that because it
would have been uh it would have been
difficult but you know naturally I do
kind of have a uh a little bit of like a
valley girl accent so I had to get rid
of that I had to go a little bit like
graeler a little deeper because Blair's
tough you know she's she might not have
the accent and the reason you know going
back to is I asked Seth I said are you
sure cuz I I'll figure it out we can
figure it out and he said no she's just
she's a little more educated than them
she's a little smarter so that was uh I
got very lucky but no yeah and it's a
great character you do a great job so
it's cool to see the variety too which I
like and um max I was just thinking
while watching this that you know you
have to look down so much at your scene
partner being a teddy bear so is your
neck killing you on set like do you have
to do neck exercises like how do you get
through this a little bit that's
actually a really good question yeah I
yeah that's that's crazy I do have like
a pinched nerve in my neck that I had
even before shooting that on
particularly long days I'd just be like
okay all right going again yeah I also
love having to look down at my scene
partner so much because everybody's best
angle of themselves is from directly
below uh everybody's favorite angle is
you know famous when you're going like
this yeah of course of course no that
that's a great answer and no it's so fun
seeing you with Ted how well you do
having that as a scene partner so it's
great and I'm excited for everyone to
see this it's out today and what's cool
is the full season's out on peacock so
you can binge it in one shot it's so
much fun thank you Georgia and Max for
joining me today and I hope to talk to
you in the future absolutely you too man